needs no introduction we've been talking
about his tournament for about a week
and a half rex we've seen it all at
previous thing field cops with offi
seven zero we saw magnus take this
tournament in the first uh edition but
this one was a completely different
beast tell us your thoughts about this
one well it's it's pretty hard to
comment on this i mean you know how do
you get that kind of
excitement however nefarious it might be
but we did get it you know and it is
what it is
uh but you gotta say the players have
rebounded and added a lot of excitement
to this event as if nothing happened you
got to give them a lot of credit uh like
the game last night between fabi and
neiman that was
exciting and i love the commentary
people saying they're going back and
forth bobby can't make up his mind to go
for a win or not and he said that in the
interview he doesn't know which way it's
going that makes it all pretty exciting
for us
low-level players you know it's actually
been a great event in terms of chess and
it's been headlined in different ways by
two 19 year olds that's right how do you
feel that alireza farouza has been doing
here he said his dream was to play at
the club but it seemed like the dream
was for us to see him play i think
that's absolutely true it was a dream
fulfilled for us we need more players
like him although i don't think there
are many more like him
but he's fabulous he's a fine young
gentleman
and hans niemann had a lot of excitement
he's not having the success that farouza
did but not many people can
but overall it's been exciting for all
the players
you know and uh
watching a quick draw this morning with
mvl
and farouza that was kind of interesting
in itself
joey and i are lucky enough to have
coffee with them later i thought they
were just drawing their game just to be
with us you know
well that is why we come to the same
field cup to hang out with you
[Laughter]
what's impressed you uh from this
tournament from the last one from the
players that are new perhaps to the tour
i think the fighting spirit of this one
you talk to the players and you you see
how genuinely excited they are how happy
they are
despite the way things have gone they
they've all bounced back it's been a
really good event i think for the entire
chess world and the players and of
course the three greatest commentators
in the world we owe it all to them
there's no question about that i always
appreciate that tell us a little bit
about that from the pr perspective we
saw this just explode over the internet
of course unprecedented news when magnus
carlsen withdrew but when were you
informed about this how did you learn
about it well i was watching
when it happened and but i was talking
to uh anastasia last night about it and
i didn't realize
how extensive the coverage had been
worldwide she was telling me the hits
were between two and three million
every day i mean this is stunning
you know uh
you got to give it magnus is a great
personality and
and his actions brought some attention
to this
how do you feel personally as somebody
that puts together the best tournament
in america arguably one of the best
tournaments in the world every single
year and this one we always look forward
to having the world champion participate
and boom he just leaves well you don't
want to see something like that happen
you never want to see a top player you
never want to see any player leave under
questionable circumstances so it's
unfortunate but it is what it is and i
have total respect for all the players
involved
and i have no ill will toward any of
them i think they're they're all great
and they've all tried to do a good job
and they've worked in accordance with
their own best conscience well we'll see
magnus back in events
oh i'm absolutely sure he likes being
here he's he was very public about that
and i've heard him say that himself a
couple years ago i was walking out of
the club with he and his father and he
looked around he said dad this place is
really nice why don't we move here well
you know that just filled me with joy
absolutely no already himself said it
how it was spectacular the high class
that surrounded the club and of course
everything inside that club even though
they were in the middle of renovations
yeah i know that is really amazing you
got to hand it to joy and tony and all
of her staff i mean joy bray is the
brave the greatest and you know the
problem with my saying that is she's
probably listening right now
she's going to take it all very
seriously you know so how do i get out
of that one uh no but they've done a
fabulous job
and uh you're absolutely right i mean
this neighborhood is one of the best
neighborhoods in the world like you i've
been all over the world and i've seen
them
i don't think it's really hard to
compare to this one we're surrounded by
culture and beauty and great
architecture
and tremendous history
and now the chess club just gets better
and better no it's one of the best
places to have the center of the chess
world every year especially during the
sing field club guys join the
conversation here with the man himself
uh i you you brought it up rex uh
culture and i know not only humana
culture bobby fisher
has always been
an important part
of your awareness of the chess
world and
across the street the world chess hall
of fame
arguably one of the greatest exhibitions
of bobby fischer memorabilia of the 1972
world championship match talk a little
bit about that because i know
you have a lot of bobby fishermen well
this is sort of a dream come true and
around here you know we've been talking
about it for several years we knew it
was coming
and
just seeing it realized is amazing
seeing all the artifacts and the
memorabilia
is incredible seeing that table and
those pieces that they actually handled
and played is amazing and i like yasser
had the good fortune at one time to meet
bobby fischer i like to tell people i i
taught him a lot of chess but they all
know better
no but but it's a fabulous and i think
it's going to be extremely well attended
it has already i see people walking out
of there waving the posters and the
signs that they bought
and it's really a good thing it's great
for the city it's great for chess no i
have to say that the world chess hall of
fame exhibit right now of the 50-year
anniversary between of the match between
bobby fischer and boyz basket it's just
spectacular they have so many different
things i didn't even know existed
there's so many booklets that fisher
used seeing the boards themselves the
pieces themselves the fact that they
played game three on the pieces that we
have on display that wonderful knight h5
that fisher played in the binoni i mean
having that set you taught him you know
of course doubling your pawns come on
rex i'm gonna ask you something outside
of bobby fisher you can invite a player
that was at his peak to participate in
one of the singfield cups
who'd you choose boris baskey boom
boom now you know
we thought going back five six seven
weeks we thought this was all under
wraps you know we were working hard to
prepare it nobody knew about it and out
of the blue i mean truly out of the blue
joy bray gets a phone call from france
it's from boris baskey jr now you talk
about a secret not well kept that is it
you know
and he he was gracious and wonderful we
sent three people over he had loads of
memorabilia he said my father has lots
of memorabilia he would like to loan to
your tournament what a wonderful gesture
from a wonderful man boris baskey you
know that's just so typical of him no i
have to say if you have a chance to
check out this exhibit like for sure
stinkfield cup is great to watch and it
makes it even more worthwhile to go in
front and check out what we have at the
world chess hall of fame
yeah
you're right thank you very much no rex
thank you for letting everything that
happens here in the central west end is
definitely thanks to you we have the
tournament it's been fantastic we've had
such drama but the games i mean the
games have been amazing they are amazing
and they're even made better by
yasser and peter i mean can you ima and
you can you imagine that
it's like having three hairy carries in
one room
oh dear rex thank you very much for all
you thank you for chess
we are
very very grateful indeed uh peter any i
i've been agreeing kind of sitting here
and nodding nodding in agreement but one
thing i that's always struck me when i
when i speak uh with rex is uh
how much he how deeply he cares about
this being sort of a continuation of st
specifically saint louis chess history
and his knowledge about the
his knowledge of the saint louis history
and uh
it's just wonderful to see uh you know a
person care about sort of legacy and
continuity and uh
uh
continuing to preserve those traditions
uh so yeah thank you very much for
everything you're doing here it's thank
you peter that's very kind it's
wonderful to be part of it
thank you once again uh rex
gracious thanks gracious thanks
jumping back into the games
ya